i was going to ask you about this i was
like you're mentioning that you're the
one writing the sheet music basically
how do you how do you come across the
knowledge of every single instrument you
want to use pain and suffering because
it's like because obviously if you're a
violinist you do violent yeah you're
very good at it yeah like you're like i
need to know this russian synth also can
i find the harp and i need to write that
like this sounds like an overload of
knowledge that you have to acquire or
have a rough understanding of almost
everything
um so um
yeah so when you're orchestrating for a
larger ensemble so harp is a very very
specific and very unique instrument yeah
it works on a pedaling system which um i
understand the concept of but don't know
how to like achieve right so what i
would say is that you're kind of working
up your base knowledge of certain things
right obviously like when i write
woodwind
like woodwind sectionals uh it's it's a
lot kind of
let's call it more natural yeah do you
understand that yeah so okay i
understand if i do something quite [ __ ]
that there's going to be a will or a way
to kind of get it done yeah that's why i
hear like a quite a few flu passages and
whatever so because like you hear a lot
of flute jumping up and down and up and
down and up and down because like ah yep
it's like you you should it's just your
comfort instrument right he's just like
but then when it comes to say dimitri's
violinist because he is such a [ __ ]
boss i can do like what would normally
be insultingly stupid [ __ ] but he'll be
like okay let's go and just [ __ ] yeah
i can do this
and then he's [ __ ] like does all
these different permutations of it yeah
just do a bunch of texts and just cut it
together it just sounds [ __ ] awesome
yeah and then you just sat there like oh
[ __ ] it actually worked yeah and then
like so it's literally like [ __ ]
trial and error what's going to say yeah
um a couple of risks but then also yeah
like i did learn orchestration yeah yeah
yeah which is basically just going
through yes going through every
instrument and it's been like what does
and does not work and you just build it
up so flute but then there's ultra flute
bass flute and then it basically has
certain characteristics in which you
know if you go too high on the baseline
it's going to start doing overtones
right right right
and the flute or the piglet won't do in
the same way would you say there's
always a concern then when you're like i
don't want this guy to think i'm a
[ __ ] idiot for writing this and then
handing it to your professionals like
that's why i like giving me a chill
atmosphere in the studio okay okay
for example that's why you see in that
in that that's where you start people
mates
yeah it's like
i like you want to bring your a game so
yeah you come
you come with the like the best possible
job that you could have done yeah you've
done as much research as possible
yeah yeah it's it's i mean because
that's what that's why i gained a lot of
weight in pandemics i
but i couldn't do anything like kind of
get rid of the stress because i was like
right right it's like
okay i need to do this and do that and
like like the star wars saying like you
know you want to make sure that is right
yeah yeah of course you want to bring
the best [ __ ] sheet music you want it
to be beautifully type set you want that
to be the best looking music you've ever
written right right right page and you
want the the musicians to be happy
because you want the project to go
really really well yeah yeah right
thankfully it did but like again like
you you bring your a game and then you
give the musician enough adequate scope
if there is a mistake yeah or you oh you
get yourself you know what it's almost
like you're refining the the level of
potential mistake yeah down to where
there's and like you're in a
a sphere of like safety yeah and then
within that if there's a mistake if
there's something like that oh that
dynamic doesn't work that doesn't mean
yeah
well they tell you they'll be like yeah
this part isn't really doable or like
let's just they should tell you and
that's why it's good to be like hey just
so you know if there is anything wrong
wrong tell me i don't mind yeah actually
that's why i guess
but that is literally the conversation
you have that conversation all the time
yeah yeah because you like
i don't yeah there are like there are
people that you know was like okay we
will go for a take now
okay i think
yeah like that
uh like that's fine but uh
i guess maybe like my style i'm trying
like my style right now at least is like
yeah i'm just happy to be here and i
just you know i want to make this i'm
just a mate i'm just amazed i haven't
composed anything yeah yeah
but they keep rehiring
just tell me if i'm being a [ __ ]
just just
like just we're gonna sit down we're
just going to play it yeah there's any
questions i've you know i've done my
best to make sure that you guys have a
good time yeah yeah and if you do a good
time like i feel like you just because i
was explaining to you this to you last
night as well um like there's a couple
of
thoughts of school about like how many
takes you should do right and
you know in certain countries there'll
be like one two or three or four takes
that you'll do or do a run through and
then they'll be like okay
right and then there's other times where
um there are there's other types of
composers
where you'll basically like do
like multiple takes even like what would
be considered potentially unnecessary
takes just to get like different kind of
like permutations and certain phrases
right so you can cut together and kind
of do like kind of different things yeah
yeah yeah yeah so um i'm in that second
part i was going to say that right you
seem like you are really not economical
but at the same time um there have been
like more than capital there's been
countless times where i've been able to
basically
like create a really cool sort of
almost like a combination or like an
amalgamation what am i saying
yeah yeah of like different takes
like you know i like oh like
bar 34 beat four
the cello like kind of slipped a little
bit on that one note right and it sounds
a little [ __ ] up but let's cut that in
because i like the [ __ ] upness yeah
and then go back to like this other tape
which is a bit more clean some of that
and then let's bring in this sort of
thing the more you're telling me about
it the more stressed out i'm getting
like what if you know because if you
have like you said you had uh three of
each uh instrument earlier
what if like one guy's just sick it
doesn't turn up well like that's that's
not a thing not a thing it shouldn't be
what if uh like someone's uh they gotta
fly over the visa gets delayed or
something and it's like oh crap i need
to find another guy like this sounds
like i'm getting stressed out they're
messing all these moving parts if it
makes you feel better they're already
there okay yeah they're already there
these guys do that day and night
if there was if there was someone that
was unable to come in because they were
sick or whatever the next person's just
there okay right right right right one
regular whole process yeah i mean okay
so in that case you'll hire you're
hiring maybe not just a room but
there'll be what's called a fixer an
orchestra will fix it you will help get
everything who is like they organized
everything because
you don't know everyone you really don't
right so you're you're coming into a
situation where you're you're hiring a
service so you're hiring somebody
and you're hiring like normally
more times than none i've seen that the
studio and the um like musician hiring
service are one in the same right
they come hand in hand so okay if you're
hiring a ceo have you got musicians no
okay use use the person who fixes it all
out right now and then i'll say okay
well we need x amount of yay we need x
amount of yeah would win this
and then let's say you know someone
doesn't rock up they just make a phone
call and i've seen it happen like it
it's like oh uh something didn't happen
uh can you come in yep great see you in
10 minutes wow right wow just kind of
like you can tailor the session uh i i i
i
bought like if unless there's a request
for them to use their own conductor i
always get up my own stuff yeah we have
a lot more control i'm a bit control
freaky so right so um i'm sure i'm sure
we all i figured
yeah of course you all appreciate being
very very anal about control yeah but uh
yeah just like let's say for example
like you're missing a cell i'm just
using an example
say the cello you know chalice falls
down and you know
explodes
let's go there
how about that you're about to say some
real [ __ ]
um
so yeah let's say like chalice is
suddenly you know exploited explosions
just like thanos snaps out yeah
that was a very good snap yeah that was
a firm snap ah do you know why
conducting is you to go one
two
three
four then why were you
[Laughter]
oh
let's say okay let's quickly switch over
to like a different um
let's switch over to like justin and
viola yeah yeah yeah only drag for like
10 minutes okay let's record that great
finish that welcome back jealous let's
go back to that
right right right
by working through it yeah you work in
tandem with what's called a session
producer which is basically someone in
the booth if it's not you like the
composer can produce their own session
if they are hiring a conductor to
conduct yeah but if you've decided to
conduct yourself you work in tandem with
the producer or maybe two producers in
the booth saying yep we've got that take
no don't be a psychopath about that move
on please sort of because
you can get in your own head especially
yeah yeah yeah exactly okay yeah
actually i remember you saying like have
you got it haven't got it like in in a
video when you're talking about how you
have to i think you were on scene like
it's like the boys club or something
like that and you were talking about how
you you're doing takes or interviews and
stuff yeah and then you're like have we
got it do we need to go again yeah
uh what would be the word nervousness
about okay do we actually have the
content yeah we do not have the content
we need to go again
yeah yeah right it's important yeah yeah
but if you're filming it and you're also
you know in the shot yeah then you've
got to go back and you've got to go back
yeah yeah yeah
but if but having someone behind the
camera or in this case in the in the
recording booth yeah saying no we got it
it's chill let's move on yeah that kind
of moves great like nice reinforcements
right yeah
yeah it's like i guess the
they i mean they should but like the
cameraman he's like getting the shot but
he doesn't necessarily give a [ __ ] if it
doesn't look great sometimes it depends
okay i would avoid that yeah i would
recommend that and it's also sometimes
you they don't know what kind of shot
that you want yeah as like normally if
there's with a director they don't have
as much investment as like say someone
you hire to be invested like that yeah
well i mean if you're hiring a session
producer they should right so
you're hiring someone who's like is his
job is to be as invested as you right
yeah so but obviously not everyone will
because otherwise he's just a guy at the
booth yeah yeah yeah no i do see where
you're coming from now so
there are times when someone is just
saying okay have we got the you know the
the standard yeah yeah we got it right
you go back and you're like you didn't
have it
but then that would be hopefully where
you could that that would maybe where
experience kicks in and you're saying
yeah no we're gonna go again yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah at the end of the day you
kind of drive the train right people are
really supporting you people are there
doing their job but right between you
and maybe like the music supervisor or
something like that you guys are driving
that train yeah you've got to be like on
it and yeah this is where it's not just
a physical job it's also super mental
yeah
you've got to focus on not only if
you're especially conducting you've got
the physicality of making sure okay cue
that person in keep on going like that
yeah you come in you come in b3
but you know
you're cueing people even though you can
do it but
you know
through the physical act of conducting
it's not just about keeping tempo which
to be fair everyone's got to click in
their ears yeah yeah really matter too
much but what it's about is coaching
more performance out of it yeah it's
actually more
like like you're basically just like
micro management yeah yeah yeah yeah
hopefully in like a positive way right
yeah yeah yeah but it's like for example
if i'm going like this to you i'm like
okay sing things
sing and then okay on that last one that
is like sing more yeah right
yeah
do it again
because that like sounds a bit
constipated but at the same time it's
like okay that should hopefully coax a
little bit more you know yeah push a
little harder yeah so if you're if
you're doing that at the same time
you're also listening to everyone else
in your headphones
[Music]
making sure that everyone else is
playing it so god yeah so you're doing
that over and over again for nine hours
a day yeah